i'm i'm actually getting emotional right
now because
i just remember looking out my window
and flint and just wanting to be
something
just feel like this man do something
when you leave
that [ __ ] in his head and it finds you
and it takes you
and you're like whoa where am i going
where am i going yeah what the [ __ ] what
happened how did i get here yes
[Music]
hey we're hot boxing i'm mike tyson i'm
up in britain
and we have a spectacular guest today
dude terry crews
hell yeah hell yeah terry
for those who can't see it is the the
the pecs are popping right i'm sure they
can see it
brother what do you think i'm talking
about what do you think about guys
commenting on your pecs and stuff
yeah uh stuff that you call um toxic um
toxic masculinity yeah yeah and then
what's the guy named rashid come on you
know his name yeah
yeah you know what i'm supposed to talk
about he was talking some crazy [ __ ]
well
first of all first of all um man i don't
back
i i literally love i was built
for this kind of discussion you know
what i mean um
i don't shy away didn't talk about
anything but some people you know i
don't know
in our community some people think
they're the one they dictate how we
should live our life however men should
live and how they should be
how their masculinity should be um
produced and how it should be forwarded
to
what particular group of people or
whatever you know yeah i mean
well first of all in our community like
you said with black people
if you're not discounted black if you're
not my kind of black you are all of a
sudden
not black people like hey terry crews
ain't black no more and i'm like when
did that happen i had the right i had
the right
i didn't realize and grow up that people
were different dude that's what i
you know i have to grow up and realize
that we're different we're not all the
same but if you get caught in that um
that um that group of people of that set
of people that believe that we have to
be this way
and able to survive i'm gonna say
something that's gonna be very
controversial say it
these are the same people that killed
malcolm x well yeah you understand like
when i say
when malcolm x was malcolm x and then
all of a sudden he decided
i'm changing all of a sudden he went to
mecca
and he decided i need a new way all of a
sudden he saw different colors
worshiping and he was like you know what
i need to leave i need to
get out of what i was in and i need to
embrace this thing on a worldwide global
level and there were a whole lot of
black people who wasn't down with them
then
and they let him go they literally
turned on him
and again i don't know all the details
but when i look at it and i said
when he died he died alone the community
was not the same community that was like
we want malcolm and then when he turned
all of a sudden you did something a
little different than they wanted
and boom and this is the stuff we're
talking about now often years later
we look back and they go oh man malcolm
x was a genius
same thing with mlk mlk had so many
people that was like man you need to
just go smack a fool
and mlk was like no no no
we going to do it non-violent everybody
thought that was weak everybody thought
you was a punk
everybody thought that and lo and behold
this is how you change the world though
you know what i'm saying
and that's controversial it's very
controversial you know you can look at
two ways
we don't know maybe um not being
non-violent maybe that would just took
us a different direction
right you know we never went that route
most some people did they had different
um fractions that went to violent the
black panthers they had um
true newton yeah but remember they were
right
they were right what's the other guy
named stokey carmichael michael listen
but first of all i believe in that now i
i first i
i me i'm only talking about my
experience me
i ain't talking about nobody else's
experience but my experience growing up
in flint michigan
uh where i came up and i literally
graduated
class of 86 the whole auto industry was
dying
the crack epidemic was at an all-time
high
people would flint michigan led the
nation per capita in murder for almost
12 13 years straight i had friends
dead in jail people would die it was
crazy
and people and people always want to
talk anybody wants to talk about
violence
has never seen it i'm trying to tell you
when you talk about
violence for real and you see it it's
like
it's one of the scariest most crazy
things you've ever seen in your life and
people want to you know
yeah yeah smoking fight did it and man
when you see somebody
get smoked when you really understand
the ramifications of like this kind of
thing man i had
i beat up my own father i beat my
father's
ass as a grown man because he was a
drunk
i went through my whole life him beating
up my mother
oh this is my earliest memory was him
hitting
my mother in the face as hard as he
could that's my earliest memory
and that told me oh damn it's his world
okay
and he ruled through intimidation he
ruled through physical force
and we were scared of him man the whole
my whole life i was scared of my father
i peed in the bed
i was 14 years old cause i wake up i
didn't know what was gonna happen i was
afraid of my father
i would never fight myself come on man
world champion because i know he would
shoot you he would kill you he would
kill you i knew that for a fact i knew
as an adult i was always respectful
he needed money i would make sure i gave
him money and not gonna be on his bad
side
but see i did the same thing i did the
same thing i was a pleaser i was like
you want another beer here's another
beer you want this
yes sir yes sir but put your pants up my
pants up sir
but this is the thing i became a grown
man
and i said look i'm gonna bring my
family home i'ma bring my kids home
for christmas just i was already i'd
played in the nfl i'd done this thing
i said listen i'm gonna bring my kids
home for christmas i said please please
just don't act up just please
my kids have never seen it my kids have
never seen nothing crazy
man i bring them home i'm out there
hanging out with my wife and my kids i'm
actually hanging out with my wife we
about to go out
my kids are left in my home man i get a
call from my aunt oh my god
my god he hit your mama he knocked her
two
sideways he knocked your tooth loose
i said what are you kidding me like
i spent my whole life trying to keep my
kids out of this
and all of a sudden i bring you home one
time i just ask you promise me you're
not gonna trip
and he just did that to show me he could
do whatever he wanted to do
i brought i said go get to take the kids
to the aunt house
i dropped my wife off at the ass house
drove to the house
i had went home he was still there
i said man it's me and you and i beat
his ass
for hours now mike let me tell you
something
what blew me away though i thought
i would feel some satisfaction from that
i thought
i would get some sort of release
and i got nothing man look i was sitting
there
like this don't work dawg this don't
work
i got revenge wait i got all the revenge
i wanted he was lying there talking
about doing him please please
cause he old man now you know what i
mean and i'm going
all right hey man all this beating
people ass
stuff it don't work i mean when you look
at the results of what happened i was
like
i was left emptier i was just like him
and i was done i said you know what
it's just not the way this is not the
way to go i i choose to not
not go that route so tell me do you feel
you have a temper
oh definitely yeah oh that's how you
going to nfl you play off pay
you play off play i play seven years on
the nfl on pain
straight up i was angry i was mad and
that's how allow you to put your head
into anything
me too i did that with boxing and then
but what this is was tricky then i
finished boxing that doesn't work in the
real world
it doesn't no that stuff doesn't work in
the real world being tough to the work
in the world gotta be smart homie it's
like the military oh
it's like the military you imagine when
you're in a war zone yeah
you know mike i know i know
vicariously your experience you know
what i mean i don't i didn't live it but
i see
but i know the people you i i understand
you
because i feel your pain i feel a lot of
what you came up in
and i understand how you became the
the best boxer who ever lived i
definitely understand it
but that [ __ ] don't work in the real
world not a little bit
wait man wait first of all i had so many
things man i was yelled
and this is this i never hit my wife
never did anything like that but man
i yelled the hell out of like i would
create such a scene
that was like man this dude look my wife
had seen me throw people over her head
but then she was the one who told me
terry listen listen
we gonna lose everything we gonna lose
everything i had a hair pin
trigger what you say [ __ ] what you say
you know what i mean that's all it took
and all of a sudden i would snap it and
dude listen
to you i'm glad you didn't reach that
level you see it i was that guy
tripping hitting off hitting people
because they [ __ ] with me too much
for autographs i [ __ ] knock them out
a son or break the [ __ ] jaw next week
but know what i started signing those
checks and that
broke my spirit oh these are getting
four million dollars i don't even know
these guys
eight million i don't know these who are
these guys
just because i was stupid i was you know
i hit these guys
man i had also some dick i had um
pensacola commercials and all that stuff
man
now i became one of those crazy guys
that scared me and stuff
you know you can't you can't do that you
got to be cool with that you got to
control your temper because they'll
freak out those people in hollywood
that's
down with you and then freak out mike
could you please tell the black guys
freak them out can you tell these people
can you wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait man can you tell these people
please
because this is the thing people get mad
at me listen everybody looking at me
they're like hey man
d.l ugly went up on me said i should
have smacked this dude
this wait the head of william morris
wait the head of the movie department
this dude runs up on me grabs my balls i
and then they act like i didn't do
nothing like i just sat there and let it
happen did not happen
i grabbed the dude i'm like yo hey hey
dude what are you doing
of course he was high i mean he was on
something he wasn't drunk
he was on something what did he say how
did he come here he was
no he no you know how you tweet you ever
see somebody tweaking
that's i i came up and played i've seen
them tweaking and it's like the eyes are
all crazy
and lips he was sticking his tongue out
he was coming over me like
i was like yo hey man what are you doing
i didn't understand it
because i don't do that stuff he came up
and he just stuck
he grabbed my stuff i said he make whoa
whoa whoa my wife is right there
i grabbed his hands and they get back he
comes back again i said look man
hey hey hey stop i said what the [ __ ]
are you doing
he's like ah and i knew he wasn't there
you know what i mean now
i still want to kill him you understand
what i mean like
i could have easily do you doubt the
fact that i could have put this man on
the floor
nobody but but what would the headline
have been the next day
he was i just brushed up against the guy
and he knocked me out
i was just standing there and he they
touched my eye
am i right i'm in that situation where
i've hit guys or something and i thought
i was in the right because they were
[ __ ] me but when you put your hands
on somebody you're not in the right but
they were [ __ ] with you right yeah
but um i didn't know that
i started hitting these guys and nowhere
else too i gotta remember i'm i'm a
[ __ ] headway champ i'm knocking these
guys out i'm breaking their cheekbones
the eye sockets
hey man this is just crazy the regular
people in the streets you know
that's crazy that's just um see um
that's what happened to me my first my
all my first um
actions with the smash kill this
[ __ ] who you you know the [ __ ] i
am [ __ ] that was my first time reaction
that's why i got
all my [ __ ] but mike mike let me tell
you something man
all i could think about was
my son wouldn't be able to see me oh no
my daughters wouldn't be able to see me
yeah that's my experience
my wife wouldn't be able to see my kids
behind the [ __ ] glass thing
man listen mike man tell them man
because these man let me tell you
everybody has this fantasy they have a
movie in their head
where you could just walk around shoot
people and go home
and kill people like knock people out
and walk away in real life
they do it though they do it though
brah i listen first of all and everybody
and then other people they bring up
videos they're like man this guy he
worked at popeyes and he smacked this
dude i like look man
i lose a popeye's job i lose a job at
popeyes
but you telling me to lose hundreds of
millions of dollars of what i'm doing
right now
you ain't gonna get no no you ain't
getting me like that not
no you didn't get terry crews that day
no you know that um i mean once they get
rid of you they tell let all their
friends know don't [ __ ] he's a bad
[ __ ]
all their friends know not to mention
they don't take a chance
no they don't i did everything that
everybody wanted him to do
and you see where i landed up wow
dude first of all uh that is the
the best example ever mike
ended up in jail yeah mike they took
they tried to they take tried to take
everything from her to kill him
tried to kill him i'm 50 years old i'm
old enough to see how this [ __ ] plays
out
they want you to kill yourself they want
you to get depressed i want to start
using throughout
the season i tell you yep and i never
did
but first of all i started to realize
man hold up oh
now you gotta i'm gonna finish this
story with what happened with my father
years later i came back
and you know what i did i apologized to
him
i apologized to my father i said man
look
i should have never done that i was out
of sort i said even though you were
wrong i made myself even more wrong
and i said dude i said you know what
i i terry crews i said i am
thankful if i had a chance
to pick my parents i would choose you
mike he started crying dude he started
crying
he was like i'm sorry i'm sorry for what
i did to your mother
i'm sorry for what i did to y'all it was
messed up see man see
that's all we're looking for man like
look i i
as a i'm a grown ass man but we are just
looking for people to recognize us
for who we are and literally look at us
and love us
anyway well i'm too scared that's my
fault so he wouldn't there give me no
[ __ ] forgiveness are you [ __ ]
crazy
hey i i listen yeah
you [ __ ] crazy but you gotta
understand i didn't know what he was
gonna say
i was ready for anything i was ready for
[ __ ] you man
i was ready for that exactly i was ready
for that don't touch me get out of here
but this is the thing when he broke down
i gave him a hug
and i'll be honest with you we still
don't talk it ain't like we became
buddies
forgiveness ain't about like all of a
sudden we it nothing happened
forgiveness is for me forgiveness is so
i can move on so i can just like
wipe my hands and go to the next step
but accountability
is different accountability says hey man
i don't trust you
and you're gonna stay way over here but
i forgive you
but i also know who you are and so
it's all people think forgiveness means
oh now he gets carte blanche
no that ain't how it works i definitely
said look
i'm through and we still don't talk but
you understand where i'm at and i
understand where you are
and now we're at peace and that's good
and that's a peaceful life after that
there's a whole lot of people are let go
man a whole lot of you have to
do a whole lot of people you know i was
let go people have loved so dearly
you know you loved them you know but
they were toxic
you know you guys energy together it
didn't work out
you know in a prosperous way hey you
know you don't want to do anything it's
great
it's true if you want to live and do
something like it's just not working out
you know what trips me out to you know
people what about toxic femininity i'm
like hey man look
you know i'm gonna let the women talk
about that i just know to do
look i all i stay in my browns you know
what i mean people say well what about
white people
hey man i ain't white i'm not what now
again we all know what's up if somebody
messes with us as black people i get it
but i
am here to deal with my community i can
speak on what i see
i can speak right look men need to hold
other men accountable
that's what i always say do you have a
charity oh yeah i got plenty yeah i got
plenty there's rise
uh rise group which is the sexual
assault um
awareness the sexual assault bill rights
then i'm on a polaris group which is all
about
human human trafficking and fighting
that um
i i make sure i stay on it man those are
my those are my things in fact
polaris is the ones that got my money
from lip sync battle we did that
i gotta bring that up it's awesome man
we got deep quick didn't we yeah real
date man we just dove in the deep end
yeah listen we'd have to do research on
you and i was watching you on dr phil
and you were discussing um
yeah pornography yeah and i was saying
to myself how do you get off that how do
you how do you
stop doing that you know because my i
had um
could i i would i would watch it openly
i would never hide out watching my wife
would come in what the [ __ ] are you
watching
watching you know and then when he was
expressing it
why why did he hide from it you know
what no see my see
man let me tell you something man mike
i knew i had a problem dude i was like
because you know
the thing is people say man look
pornography hey man
it's natural like you know i'm a man so
it's natural
i don't know no that's interesting i
have to comment on that that's what
people say
they say it's natural right because um i
don't know because i mean i want to do
weird stuff with my wife my wife
thing looks at me weird sometimes i want
to do some weird [ __ ] you know what i
mean
and i guess that freaked out a little
bit you know let me tell you stop
watching it stop watching me because i
know she was stuck and i guess
my son or somebody one day came by
looking used my phone and for porn on
the phone
and [ __ ] i just had to stop we got
really out of hand
first of all and i got tired of [ __ ] my
dick was always scabbed up from jerking
off
my dick my skin is all peeled off man
i [ __ ] can't [ __ ] can't do nothing ah
you took eyes all sore
hey hey man first of all listen
you'll never there'd never be enough
porn to satisfy you
[ __ ] yeah it'll never be enough it's not
healthy it's not
hey man look there's never enough yeah i
remember like man you you could spend
three hours looking for the perfect
image
it's real dark you see somebody smacking
somebody and wait choking somebody
yeah i thought oh did you feel like did
i watch that did i
was i part of that because you watched
it out there and this is always
darker and darker i'm watching i'm
scared somebody's going to check in on
me saying mike is watching crazy [ __ ]
and the whole world's going
to be watching this [ __ ] my i have a
daughter and my fear
is that you know she's in school
and some kid who has a phone [ __ ]
shows her some video or something i've
heard stories from parents about being
their kid is on a school bus some
innocent
you know 12 year old girl and some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] boy takes his cell phone and
shows her some [ __ ] porn video
evil and just scars the girl yeah but
you know situations like that
we live in this world and um he's just
going to have to get a visit from her
brothers or cousins or something
and somebody uh somebody has to explain
to them certain things like that we have
no control over you know when they're in
school we have no control over i know
i said this and it's funny i said this
at a women's conference
which blew everybody's mind but i
remember in the nfl going to
you know one of the things you know you
stop it and you go to matt atlanta and
they go to magic city to go to the strip
club and i went with the guys
right maggie city's just meant you you
know yeah
it's it's a den of iniquity i used to go
out you smell it first oh man
i forgot when i'm in mexico i don't know
what i'm thinking i'm thinking the
[ __ ]
guys had on the slave ships coming back
[Music]
wait man you know something wrong like
you know you just go in there like oh
man
i descended into hell i descended into
hell first of all that's just how i was
living back there no
no listen hey man i was there i seen it
yeah and then i really want to hear your
because i played in the nfl yes
i played six years okay okay the culture
is so much
what you're saying and to hear you talk
about it
it's fun it's like every guy coming out
of football is trapped in this
psychological prism of how you're
supposed to be
let me i i'm gonna tell you have that
toxic this
is
because you think i'm at the strip club
it's it's natural
but what's happened this is what i said
at the women's conference what happens
is
you see the girl and she's doing her
thing
but then she starts talking and you're
like why are you talking
shh like you're ruining it and don't
talk about your bills or your kids or
you're there
hey shut up shut up shut up you know why
because she's becoming a human
the realization is that you are in love
with an image
you are in love with something that's
not real but once they start talking and
it's like this why is this irritating
see the problem is
and this is this thing men got mad at me
men got mad at me because i pulled it
out there
but the thing is i said you are not i
said
when men are like that even with porn or
with strip club
or anything like that women are all the
way
human this is what i mean they're like
they're only like three-fifths human
yeah because you you know as long as you
just stay smiling because it's the
fakest smile you've ever seen
but you don't care just fake smile fake
it
and do what you do but the thing is is
that when somebody's not human you can
do anything you want to it's a fantasy
yeah you could do it the same way
they dehumanized them three-fifths
humans they know
they're not human this is not pain it
doesn't hurt them and that's how
they can be changed up in the cold no
problem and yeah women when some women
people do look at women like that
listen and what's happening now like we
did the gillette commercial about
you know talking about masculinity the
whole thing and men
flipped out they were like oh man
they'll be telling us what to do and the
whole thing
but all i can contrib all i can really
compare it to because what are we saying
is just be good
be a good guy that's what the gillette
commercial was like hey man
be a good guy you know just don't dog
people out
people once got mad at me was like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you i ain't being no good man i
believe in humanity
i believe in humanity and i believe
people want to do good i believe people
want to do good but some people just
can't do it
well but but this is the thing this is
the thing i believe everybody's bad but
you're so no no and let me tell you
they're not
there are no evil people there's only
evil thinking
that's it if you think evil you are evil
but once you start thinking good
all of a sudden uses good people but
what happened was man
because we all have that we all have it
first of all
i made a qu i made a comment about liam
neeson tell me that i want to tell you
we're gonna bring it all up yeah
oh we gotta get out of here
tell me what happened first of all first
of all i bet you know he
confessed that he went 40 years ago he
went on a rampage
and was looking for a black man to kill
because they basically
right because his friend got raped
exactly no it was his friend got raped
was he intimate i don't know he didn't
go that deep
but the point was is that he got mad and
he was looking for a black man that
would start something with him like
he was hoping that a black man would
just you know it was wishing [ __ ] would
i wish a [ __ ] would but
no black people in this community nobody
no black people right but he went
walking around so any black man anywhere
in there
he was gonna just do it now first of all
first of all i said on online i said
look
every man in him has the greatest good
or unspeakable evil he was describing
his fork in the road it's what i said
i said he had a choice he was like and
then he went uh
now now people got mad at me black
people got mad at me they said i was
defending
liam neeson but i'm i'm just sitting
there saying wait wait
he could have done it but what the [ __ ]
did he want to kill some black one for
see but he was racist listen he was
racist at that time he decided i'm gonna
be racist
now i gotta flip people on this i gotta
flip people when
those cops who beat um rodney king yeah
got off and it started to rise oh they
beat his ass they beat his ass
wait when the riot started there were
black men
looking for white people to kill yeah
angry
dude this happens why are we acting like
it don't happen
when they pull reginald denny out of
that truck and hit him in the head with
a brick victim
they were trying to kill him first of
all i i
when those cops got off i even felt that
like you would look at white people like
you look at cops like
man and you really have a thing like now
now did i go hunting white people hell
no
that was my fork in the road but the
truth is there were people who had that
fort there were people who were walking
around with guns
in l.a i was here in l.a during the
riots
and they were walking around looking for
somebody to
to to even talk to them wrong and they
would have killed them
i telling you i know how dark
people get i know how dark i get you
understand i mean
dude i have to be nice and happy
because i can get way deeper and darker
you understand i mean yeah so i
i go shack nice i call it shack knives
so that i don't go there you know what i
mean i don't ever want to cross that
path because man let me tell you if i
start fighting
it ain't gonna be no stop yeah you know
what i mean i
cuz i don't know what else could happen
i'm and i'm sorry i'm just i'm just
spreading my heart
yeah man i'm being real what do you do
to do that terry
thank you perpetuate that it's the hell
of athena we talking [ __ ] it's a hell of
a thing when everything starts to leave
you
yeah yeah oh that's a [ __ ] such a
relief
almost suicidal you know yeah
[Music]
because you don't care no more yeah you
don't care
but see but then all of a sudden see
there's always consequences
you know what i mean like i'm gonna tell
you man like when my wife left
i would realize man that's consequences
to porn oh [ __ ]
like you know when your kids don't want
to talk to you you realize man i've been
yelling at
all of them and they're like hey what's
up and they like
and they run away you're like man
i'm not doing this right i'm not i wanna
and i realized i was gonna be my myself
man i realized
i was gonna be alone and i was like i
ain't ready for that
and i said i gotta change i gotta do
something so i went to rehab
mike i went to a doctor uh uh listen
i've been around 10 rehabs i've been
around 10 12 rehabs wanting to get it
together
wow you know what i mean have been some
psych wards and stuff i had
me saw stevo with the psych wars and
stuff necessary
yeah oh man listen um i'll be dead i
can't believe i'm alive now that's why
i'm
so very grateful i can't believe it so
beautiful mike your story is amazing
dawg
i'm i i listen first of all because
there's a lot of people
i always thought i'm some fly guy i'm
doing this i got all the money i'm doing
great nobody has it like this i'm
the next thing you know i'm in a [ __ ]
psych ward man
[ __ ] listen you know what i mean all
over the world the best women in the
world which i believe are the best women
this
children are living great and next thing
you know i'm in a [ __ ] cycloid
like listen there are people who didn't
want me to come here
and do this interview simply because
they were like well he
he did sexual crimes how could you how
could you do that and you
me too and how could you do that but
this is the thing man
this is the thing everybody forgiveness
is for everybody
and first of all first of all you paid
your price
hey man you went to jail you know what
i'm saying listen there's a lot of cats
running you went to prison
there's a lot of people ain't paying
nothing and running around doing
anything and i'm
and i'm gonna say this too and i'm gonna
tell you man
i i stand with every woman in the metoo
movement because
because first of all i remember my
mother and i remember
you know the damage she took and she
died she died he's still living
but of course she died and the thing is
is that i look at this thing and i go
my god man there's got to be a way we
need
both we it can't be all for women but
it's got to
include the men we got to bring people
back you know what i mean we got to
you know you were in the nfl you were
you were the
height of the boxing game we got to
understand that hey man
women and men are not versus each other
it's
complementary we got to compliment each
other you know what i'm saying
but that we got to bring it all in it's
going to be difficult you know
it's going to be messy i'm
it's going to be ugly but but my thing
is if we don't talk about it
like we're doing right now see the fact
that we talking about it hey man
10 15 years ago you couldn't even talk
about absolutely listen i have my
daughter she's in one of those lgb
and i got to really be careful what i
say around her
because she'll really respond you know i
mean
militantly now if i use certain we can't
use a [ __ ] can't you just send words
she's really upset
i got to be politically correct you know
what it's like yeah man